[Music playing]
Erdem Enan: Peak Games was founded in 2010.
Our goal is to design global technological products
And access to millions of users.
We operate from our headquarters in Istanbul, so we started targeting Turkey.
But soon we expanded to cover other countries.
We look for classic gaming experience and try to move it
For use on mobile, by creating a game with
Social activity and interaction from the audience so that users can
Social networking, enjoyment, harassment and chat in
Digital environment.
In addition, we design simplified games
-Type game levels by clicking and scrolling
And plugging.
Our goal is to upgrade all our games especially
In target markets,
And gaining world-class reputation.
Android is our top priority.
We were able to attract 65,000 times a day
From Android.
For example, for Spades Plus, more than 70%
Of your mobile earnings are coming from Android.
Most of our games depend on settings.
So offer a luxury when used in chat
And perseverance.
Attract more users on Android
Much easier than any other operating system on mobile.
Thanks to its dynamic and flexible structure, ease and speed
Optimized by repeating it, which gave us speed in providing
Solutions when there is a problem.
This gave us great flexibility,
Since most of the games are classic
Much depends on the user experience.
ELKEN ALAS BAKANI: We took advantage of the possibility
Google Play staged phishing solution before downloading
Millions of users of the game.
After adding new features to the games,
We start rolling out the update at 5% of users.
Then we study the opinions of users.
If we see that everything is going well, we start
Increase the ratio and show the game to all users.
Erdem Enan: We saw that Google App Store
The conversion rate of an application can vary by 20-30%.
We also saw that the short and long descriptions leave an impression
On the conversion rate.
The increase in the conversion rate even if it does not exceed 5%
Have a significant impact on cost versus installation,
And then affect the return on investment in marketing, which benefits
On the size of the game.
We've made great use of Android
To achieve a proliferation of international markets.
We realized that user acquisition was easier
And reaches a huge proportion.
So you can cooperate with many companies
In terms of user acquisition
Android CPA is between 30 and 40%
Lower when compared to systems
Play another mobile.
Ads are the best source of acquisition.
By connecting to all other Google products.
Allowing us greater opportunity to review
For the success of our performance.
All this helps to create an employment opportunity for Edom
For Peak Games.
Over the past three years we have been interested
Focuses on the West European and North American market,
But we are seeking to spread our games in the international markets,
Where the international market is the promising future of our business.
[Music playing]